Well, well, well.
Look at what
the black cat dragged in.
If it isn't
Sabrina Spellman.
Cheryl Blossom.
Feels like it's been
centuries, doesn't it?
Thank you for coming.
My nana and I are forever
in your debt.
Don't be ridic.
You know I'd do anything
to help a fellow witch.
Nana, Britta,
there's someone
I'd like you to meet.
Hey, ladies.
What's happenin'?
Sabrina
is a dear old friend,
and she's come here
to help us
with our little ceremony.
How do you know each other?
Oh, we have a lot
of mutual friends,
share a lot
of the same interests.
Our covens are in the same
softball league.
Sabrina is the first person
who told me
about performing
a transference.
Yes, indeed.
My cousin Ambrose
taught me how to do it.
Essentially, a transference
is a very tricky spell
that can only be performed
on a night of great
cosmic significance,
like tonight with
Bailey's Comet approaching.
Speaking of,
its nearly time.
Brittania, we witches
must spell cast alone.
Do you mind?
Yeah.
Are you ready?
OK. Let's begin.
Our flesh and blood
Are but a cage
That withers
As we wear our age
But hark
There is a way to switch
Two willing souls
With one bewitched
Let us sunder body and soul
Exchanging spirits
New and old
Our flesh and blood
Are but a cage
That withers
As we wear our age
But hark
There is a way to switch
Two willing souls
With one bewitched
Let us sunder body and soul
To exchange the spirits
New and old
It… It worked.
The transference.
How do you feel, Abigail?
Free,
at long last.
Fen's curse is broken.
Let go, Abigail.
Let go and finally
be at peace.
Reunite with
your dearest Thomasina.
Happy sad endings
are the best.